الابتسامه عد مفتاح العلاقات الانسانيه
واقرب الطرق للقلوب ولكن ماذا ان كانت هذه
الابتسامه مزيفه هل يجعلنا تصنع الابتسامه
اسعد في دراسه نشرت في نيتشر هيومن بهيفر
طلب من حوالي 3800 متطوع من تسعه عشره
دوله ان يبتسموا او حتى يحافظ على تعابير
محايد باستخدام عده دوافع مختلفه ثم تقييم
سعادتهم الدراسه اظهرت ان الابتسام كان له
تاثير على السعاده اكثر من الانشطه
البسيطه الاخرى التي تنطوي على حركات
العضلات واشارت النتائج الى ان ردود الفعل
على الوجه لا يمكنها فقط تضخيم الشعور
المستمر بالسعاده وايضا تثير مشاعر
السعاده نفسها وكتب الباحثون ان تزييف
الابتسامه يمكن ان يؤثر على مزاجنا لان
الناس يستنتجون انهم سعداء لانهم يبتسمون
كما ان الابتسام ينشط تلقائيا العمليات
البيولوجيه المرتبطه بالعاطفه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات